the problem with Afghanistan is that we
stayed too long Joe Biden sorry Donald
Trump made a deal with the Taliban that
we would be out of Afghanistan I think
it was May 1st of 2020 was that 2021
yeah 2021 yep and then Joe Biden came in
and he was an arrogant ass and he said
no we are going to leave on September
11th because I'm not going to have
Donald Trump's stupid Afghanistan
withdrawal plan so he stayed an extra
what four and a half months no didn't
get people out then the Taliban that
that's not the pro that's not the
problem with with Afghanistan the
problem with that with with Afghanistan
was he got the combat troops out what
you do is you point guns at all the bad
guys and get your people out and leave
the guys with the guns pointed at the
bad guys on the ground and the guys with
the gun with the guns they leave last
everybody out and that was the problem
so he was being killed on cars outside
the Air Force Base by Taliban he
abandoned Bagram Air Force Base